[Music]
hello i'm carl i work
on the ide team here at rstudio and
today
i'm going to be talking about how to use
jupyter with rstudio server pro
so i'm going to talk about you know why
would you want to do this how do you set
it up
how do you administer it and i'll show
you a brief little demo of it
so to start some of you may be wondering
why are we doing this
so you know r isn't going anywhere we we
very strongly believe
in in r but as a company we're very much
invested in making
our ecosystem as great as it can be and
at the same time we're committed to
supporting the open source data science
ecosystem as a whole regardless
of language choice so you know that said
r and python are not rivals
they're both great tools for data
science and we believe strongly in both
of them
and you know r's better for some things
than others and python's better for
other things
so you know combining them will provide
us the best of both worlds and give
everyone what they need to do their data
science effectively
uh so you know i barely scratch a
surface on
you know our aim as a company to you
know kind of combine
python and r and you know provide you
the best tools that you need to do your
job
uh but uh on our website we have an r
and python love story that i highly
recommend you to read as
it's it's very good and goes into more
depth about you know where we're going
as a company
you can read that on rstudio.com so
why use jupiter specifically jupiter is
well known in the python community
and it provides a lot of tooling for
working with various versions of python
seamlessly
it also provides jupiter notebooks which
many of you may know are great ways of
organizing and visualizing data similar
to our markdown documents but
it currently provide better python
integration
so why would you want to use jupyter
from rco server pro
so doing so allows you to provide a
one-stop portal
for all of your data science needs so
there's no need to manage multiple
portals and frameworks for your users
to log in and just to do their jobs
you also get all the off and
authorization benefits that you get from
our studio sessions with jupiter now and
that's a huge boon
for administrators it's also
a better user experience so right now if
you want your data scientists to use
jupiter you have to have them connect to
it via
terminal start it through the terminal
and and you know that's just
not a great user experience so you know
integrating it in with our studio server
pro
allows them to you know launch it just
like an r session and
get access to jupiter at the touch of
their fingertips
and finally if you integrate jupiter
with rstudio server pro it becomes very
easy to publish jupiter notebooks to
connect
which gives you a great sharing
ecosystem that we've built
with r but also with python
so i just want to quickly very basic
talk about architecture
just so you can kind of understand how
how this all works
so you know today we have rstudio server
pro and
now it talks to the launcher which
jonathan talked about in the last talk
i won't talk about the launcher in depth
here but basically it allows you to
launch your
r sessions and your python jupiter
sessions
potentially in the cloud via kubernetes
or slurm or also locally as well
on the local server but the key takeaway
here is that jupiter sessions require
the use of the launcher which is a new
feature in one two
and r and jupiter sessions are peers of
each other so they're treated very much
the same way
and i'll kind of explain what that means
when i do my demo
so to talk about how to use
um how to use it so
again you need the job launcher so i
won't go into detail there
there's plenty of documentation online
that you can find about that
but once you have that enabled all you
really have to do to turn on jupiter
sessions
is to flip some switches and instead of
binary path it's it's very simple
so a sample configuration file just to
enable jupiter
is this you just set the binary path for
jupiter and then turn on
labs jupiter labs for the jupiter labs
interface
or notebooks for the jupiter notebooks
interface and you can have both of those
at the same time
so i'm going to attempt to show you a
demo here
if i can figure out where my desktop is
okay so this is the rstudio server pro
home page
and you know some of you may be familiar
with this but uh you know
right now uh we can when we launch a
session
what's new is we can choose our editor
so you know before every time you would
start a new session you only had one
option which was to launch our studio
but now you have the option to start
jupiter lab or jupiter notebook
so just real quick to show you what that
might look like if i start a jupiter lab
session it shows up on the home page
and then i'm loaded into jupiter lab
very seamlessly
and then you can interact with jupiter
just like you would regular
regularly connecting to jupiter you have
access to
multiple documents at the same time
and that sort of thing so nothing
revolutionary but
it is great that you can access that
through the homepage of our studio
server pro
now i'll just quickly show you jupyter
notebook i want to show you how easy it
is to publish a jupyter notebook to
connect
so if i started a new jupyter notebook
session
and then let's create a new python
notebook
so i'll just print some
python code here and then you'll see
that in the jupyter notebook it's a
little hard to see let's make it bigger
there's this button here that allows us
to publish to connect
so if we click that it becomes very easy
to publish it all i have to do is click
publish
and then it shows up on rstudio connect
so this is the new notebook that i just
created and then there it is
very simple
so i just want to quickly talk about
best practices for
administering jupiter with our studio
server pro
i recommend that you use the default
configuration wherever possible because
you know we've put a lot of work into
making the configuration defaults just
work out of the box
with very same defaults that you
shouldn't need to be tweaking
but two settings that you may actually
want to tweak
are related to session suspension
and cleaning up automatic automatically
cleaning up sessions that were forgotten
about
um so similar to what we have today
for our sessions like suspend we we
provide for jupiter as well
and then uh when you're mounting your
nfs directory you need to mount nfs
directory so that you know users have
access to their notebooks
and if you're doing that with nfs v3 we
recommend using local lock equals all
as a mount option or just using nfs v4
otherwise you could
run into some problems there and then if
you're going to be using this with
kubernetes we recommend that you use the
r session complete rstudio docker image
so this is basically a docker image that
we publish to docker hub
that has all the our studio binaries
that you need to launch
jupiter and then it you know it has
jupiter itself
and uh like an installation of python
and then you can create derivative
images from that
to provide your users with whatever you
need in terms of python versions
so there are two plugins that we provide
for jupyter
to kind of help with the user experience
these are totally optional but i
recommend that you have both of these
installed
the first plugin is the rs connect
jupiter plugin which is what actually
allowed us
to publish the notebook to jupyter
and then the other one is the rsp plugin
which shows
notebooks on the home page so just to
remind you what that looks like
at the top you see the connect
publishing button
and then at the bottom on the home page
you'll see your recently used notebooks
on the home page as well
so in some rare cases you know jupiter
won't start right up out of the box
we try to make it as easy as possible
but there may come a time where
you know you see that your jupiter
sessions won't start for whatever reason
so if you need help troubleshooting
those issues the first thing i would
recommend to do is
run the verify installation command and
this is documented
in the rstudio server pro admin guide
it's very
very easy to use you just run it and it
gives you
information about why your job couldn't
start so hopefully you can use that
information to fix whatever's going
wrong
and if you need further help just reach
out to support
as far as next steps go if you're
interested in integrating
jupiter with the rstudio server pro
please go to
the the website on screen
solutions.rstudio.com and we have
a great primer to help you set this up
that's it
thank you
[Applause]
thanks carl we have a number of
different questions that we can go ahead
and work through
one of the questions was are all jupiter
kernels supported python r
julia et cetera are those available uh
we've just focused on the python kernel
uh for now
the one thing that i will mention is
it's just jupiter so anything you can do
in jupiter you can do here
um let's see there's another one how
does jupiter handle odbc connections to
databases is there anything specific to
our studio connect on there or
specific to rcdo server pro done there
there's nothing specific done
for odbc it should just be complete path
pass-through for whatever you have set
up with jupiter
another question why not enable jupiter
by default on our studio 1.3
i guess that means why is it not in the
open source version or
not quite sure so if there's additional
details or why is it just not enabled
because to enable it you have to
actually have it set up
and configured and installed so
basically we don't want to
forcefully turn that on if it doesn't
actually you know if it hasn't been set
up
are there any tools for admins to be
able to kill and manage jupiter sessions
so it's really easy to kill jupiter
sessions from the home page
like regular r sessions so users can
self-administer that sort of thing and
they can also
admins can see jupiter sessions from the
r studio server pro admin
page so if they need to kill sessions
they can do that very easily
will the jupiter integration be
available in the r studio desktop ide
in the future uh i
i don't know maybe perhaps
great thanks again carl
[Applause]
[Music]
you